if you go to the courses if you're
completely new to bioinformatics and you
haven't really studied how to code
one popular language to do that would be
r
how many of you already are experienced
with r okay so
if you're not an expert yet i hope that
by the end of the program you will have
enough exercise
to be able to uh feel comfortable with r
at least understanding the syntax
um and really understanding how to use
you know the different libraries that
are used in bioinformatics so to give
you an example
we're going to go to the courses tab on
the omixlogic portal and right here
let's search for genomics
so what we're dealing here with are
sequences
and these sequences commonly come
from
genomics they come from this field of
genomics that deals with analysis of
sequences
and the first thing that we'll do is
we'll go to this lesson working with dna
sequences in r okay so
if you are
following along this is the link
and here
it gives a very detailed explanation of
pairwise sequence alignment multiple
sequence alignment etc and so this is
something that you can go through on
your own
but
you should be able to start
understanding as a result of this lesson
how can we deal with these strings of
letters in the case of dna it is
t c g and a in the case of amino acids
there's 16 different amino acids or 22
and we will also see
how
we can convert these sequences compare
these sequences align them and find
differences
so
the first lesson kind of introduces us
to a critical point in coding when we
use
languages like r
languages like r
use
objects and
they store information in variables and
once we have them they can use methods
designed to work with those specific
variables and objects to perform
different types of computations on them
so for example here we can load a string
in r we use this symbol
to equal
to assign it to a particular object
and then you can see that we can perform
different functions printing comparing
converting etc
so if you click here on next you will
see that there's some more exercises on
understanding the see the uh
the syntax
and once we go through the syntax
we get to a practice and the practice
will have a console
included here which you can actually
just run and if you run it you will get
a result
now the result here is about an
alignment score so here
you can see that we loaded some strings
and we compare them and we get a score
this is a similarity score for two of
these sequences
after we do that we can compare two
other sequences so notice here in the
beginning
the beginning is almost exactly the same
between the two sequences and our score
is 102.
in the second part we can run it and we
can notice that the score is actually
different so here the score is 55.
so it went down and we can notice that
in the beginning
they are not the same
now let's try over here to do an
assignment
in the assignment if we run it
it gives us an error
so now we can't just run it we need to
understand the syntax and we need to
apply what we have learned
to the assignment that we have
so right away what do i see because we
are paying attention to this syntax we
see that this function right here is not
finished pairwise alignment should be
dnac1 dnaseq2 right so we can just copy
it from here
paste it over here
and if i run it
what will happen
i will get a result
but
my result is the answer is incorrect
okay and this is an important point
because you will always get bugs when
you are running
some script and so now your goal is to
figure out well what is wrong with this
and the wrong thing is the assignment of
course it says let's use alignment
between the exact same sequence how
would we do that well we could do that
in two ways one is we could copy the
exact same thing
or another one because we have two
objects we can just compare the same
object to itself
right
and if we do that
let's run it again
and here again something is incorrect
okay and why because it says the one
stored in dna c2
so now let's change it to dna sec 2.
[Music]
excellent now we have the correct answer
okay so this is how this works these are
exercises that are built to help you
think about
how to understand the logic behind the
analysis understand what goes into the
analysis and be able to practice it
until you get it right
so this was a little example with
pairwise sequence alignment in r
if you go over here you will find some
more practice for multiple sequence
alignment in r
and eventually you will also have an
assignment
that gives you a very practical example
about metabolism
of a
drug
where you have to write your whole code
independently okay so this is how these
work and i'll just show you
the practice example
right here
to understand
the actual
visual representation of those sequences
okay and this is a visual representation
of multiple sequences alignment
okay
what do you do
when you have learned some of these
basics like writing some code
running a pipeline now you need to get
to
a way to interpret this information
right
so to interpret this in information a
lot of times
we have to deal with data visualization
data visualization can help us
look at very complex data and simplify
it to the point that we can start making
biological conclusions and that is the
essence of bioinformatics
so here i will briefly share with you
this
colab notebook this is a notebook that
you should be able to run
in your browser
and
to run it what you should do is you
should go into the file
and
may save a copy
in drive and so if you have a google
account you should be able to do that
it guides you through all of the steps
that you need to take to start
visualizing this data so to run each box
this is a jupiter notebook so to run
each box this is written in python you
would have to run this play button or
you can go to
run all right here
okay what does this notebook do and this
is kind of giving you the vision of
where we are going with all of this
information
here we will take
some example files from this study
we will then
load one of them and we'll identify
those specific elements like prra
right
we can find them
okay if you just search for them you
will find them right here
then
we will align sequences and we'll be
able to
navigate the sequences
for the full
uh
uh spike protein
okay and this is going to be
an interactive visualization
then after that we will load in
the spike protein
and we will actually look at the
receptor binding domain
looking at specific residues or amino
acids that are important for binding
and important for other things as well
and then we will construct a
phylogenetic tree first by looking at a
network
and that network will show us
some of those viral sequences in bats
and in humans
like the rat g13 and the human
and then finally we will create a real
phylogenetic tree
to understand how that could be linked
with time
okay
any questions this is just to give you
an overview of some of the tools that we
will go through
again we will go through
our platform the t by info platform to
see how
pipelines are built
okay
is asking a question after opening
collab where you're putting this drive
link so you go to file right here
and save a copy and drive and that will
be your own notebook you can now save
this notebook and work with it in the
future